- Hi, everyone, Sal
here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to the Ed Talks live
stream subset of the Homeroom.
We have a very exciting
conversation with Beth Gonzalez,
Assistant Superintendent
of Detroit Public Schools.
So start thinking of questions for Beth,
and you can put those
in the message boards.
But before we go into that,
I'll give my standard announcements.
Reminder that we are a not-for-profit,
we can only exist through
philanthropic donations.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to khanacademy.org/donate.
Any donation makes a huge difference.
There's good analysis that
even every dollar donated
to Khan Academy has $400
to $500 of social impact.
So it's hard to find anything out there
that gives you that type of social return.
So hopefully think about
making those donations.
Special shout out to the organizations
that stepped up during COVID
when they saw that need for
Khan Academy was even larger,
traffic had gone up
dramatically to Khan Academy,
but we were running higher costs.
So special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, Fastly, and
Novartis, and many others
for helping us fill that gap.
But we still need more help,
especially we still have a
multi-million dollar gap,
going into 2021.
Last but not least,
there's a version of this that
you can get in podcast form,
Homeroom with Sal the Podcast,
check that out wherever
you get your podcasts.
So with that, I'm excited
to introduce Beth Gonzalez,
Assistant Superintendent
of Detroit Public Schools.
Beth, welcome.
- Hi, Sal, thank you so much.
So happy to be here this afternoon.
- No, we're so happy to have you.
You and other administrators like yourself
or distributors around the
country or in the world really,
have had a non-enviable job
over the last nine months or so.
I'd like to hear your narrative
of how Detroit Public Schools
has thought about
keeping students learning
as early as last March
when the schools had to
start being close physically
through the summer and
all the way until now.
- Great, yes, our roles
certainly have been dynamic,
and I have been really fortunate
to get to connect with other leaders
and like roles like mine and other cities.
It's probably one of the
most least anticipated,
greatest challenges,
but also a landscape
of opportunity as well.
So as we navigate through this,
we think really critically
about what our decisions
mean for students,
and then what does it mean for right now
and how can we use this
opportunity long-term as well.
So in Detroit, it's been a
really interesting journey.
So beginning in the spring,
obviously like most districts nationally,
without any warning sort of, we closed.
And essentially, initially,
we distributed paper packets
to students for a three-week period
that led us up into spring break.
And then during that,
almost four week timeline,
my team and other teams working
actually in our district,
about 126 educators and a
number of partner organizations
really launched what we called
a distance learning plan.
And that was where we shifted
to online instruction.
With prerecorded lessons,
we developed over a thousand of them,
we leveraged Khan Academy content
and daily instruction for
a limited period of time
with our educators,
building up on a platform
we had already been using,
but not at scale Microsoft Teams.
And what we learned in
that time was we were able
to ensure continuity of learning.
We built on the high quality
instructional materials
that we had adopted
over the last few years
to be able to continue instruction aligned
to our vision of excellent instruction,
but all of our students did
not have equitable access
to that instruction.
So some students were
watching these YouTube videos
on phones, participating in class
through Teams on cellphones, through apps,
versus actually having a stable computer.
And that is where in the spring,
our superintendent and
chief strategy officer
and senior level leaders in the district
really started thinking about how do we go
after this complete, huge
digital divide in the city
and just frankly, inequity that
still existed in our system
that wasn't present in other systems
where students were able to
just go home and use computers.
And so when we started
leading here in the district,
the device ratio was at
its best, like six to one,
making it really difficult
to actually do any at scale,
digital learning in
classrooms district wide.
So we had been doing
some really intense work
to move our schools to one-to-one.
And last spring, we were
in the last deployments
of our high school.
But really what our students needed
was devices in their homes.
And so we were very thankful
in working with the
philanthropic community
to receive a $23 million
investment for an initiative
that we called Connected Futures.
And through that, and through summer,
we deployed over 44,000 devices
to the students in our district,
which we sit just about 50,000 students.
And so through the summer,
as we reached fall,
we really worked on
closing the digital divide
in terms of access devices.
However, that did not mean
that all families and students
were well-equipped to use that device
to learn on a daily basis.
And so while we celebrated
that opportunity,
we've faced a number of challenges,
even after students had access.
And the district actually made
about a $4 million investment
in students having access
to internet connectivity
in their homes.
And that's a commitment
that we will continue.
We're constantly reflecting
on what we've been able to
accomplish, where we are,
what are the challenges
our students and families
are still facing.
Because despite having done that work,
and there's a lot of cities nationally
who have like stories,
and I think that in itself is progress.
But we still have students
that aren't able to participate
in school on a daily basis.
And we've launched a number
of things to address that,
but certainly have
still more room to grow.
And so I would describe
that overarchingly,
as sort of like what's
happened in Detroit.
And for me, one of the things,
in my role as assistant superintendent
for curriculum instruction,
teaching and learning is at the core,
the heart of what I do.
And so we have been really, really focused
on making sure that our
students have continued access
and our teachers have continued access
to high quality instructional materials
that are highly rated,
that are part of our work,
and that's part of work
we're really still pursuing
is culturally relevant materials.
And so that's a point of pride,
but there are still nuances.
There's multiple platforms
that's hard for kids
and hard for families.
So even as I share celebrations,
each of those accomplishments are coupled
with things that we're still working on
to improve what we're
doing for our students.
- And there's a lot in that.
And once again, thank
you for the heroic effort
that you and your fellow district leaders
have been doing it.
I'm curious about that percentage of kids
or whatever the percentage is
that haven't been able to engage.
How large has that been?
We've been hearing that
from a lot of districts.
I live in a middle income,
upper-middle income suburban,
small school districts,
a school teacher shares
the cul-de-sac with me,
she was telling me that
5%, 10% of her kids
haven't been engaged.
I could imagine the problem
could be worse than Detroit.
How big is the problem there
and what are the best explanations
for why these kids haven't
been able to engage,
and what are y'all trying
to keep them engaged?
- Yeah, a great question.
We've really been looking
at student engagement
and attendance from a number
of different perspectives.
Our enrollment actually, as a district,
has continued to increase.
And we were making really
significant progress
on both reducing the number of
chronically-absent students,
increasing enrollment
and increasing just healthy
daily attendance rates
district-wide with some exemplar schools.
But the pandemic has really impacted,
and our data looks similar to what it did
about two years ago.
It's not consistent.
We do have some students
who are not coming at all,
but it's inconsistent in
terms of period of the day
or day of the week.
So we're thinking about that in two ways.
The first is really intentional outreach.
And so we've leveraged all school staff
to reach out to families,
to do well checks,
to offer supports beyond
just academic support.
So we're thinking about the
mental health of the family
or what additional needs
they may have that,
whether is food insecurity
or utility assistance.
And our school culture facilitators
and our deans and our school staff,
it's all hands on deck trying
to reach out to families
to understand why their students
may not be participating.
Beyond that, we have a team
of district team members
who led a large effort,
including district volunteers
and others to canvas,
and to really go to every home
for our students who haven't showed up.
And that was work I actually did myself
in our neighborhoods,
meeting families and talking
to them face to face,
of course, outside, socially
distance, safely with masks on,
about what challenges they're facing
and communicating with them
to make sure they understand
their child does have a device,
their school's waiting for them,
and we're eager to provide
instruction and supports
to their family.
We now are at a place
where it is really about
home visits and outreach.
And so despite the increase
infection rates in the city
and the challenges in terms
of being face-to-face,
we're trying to engage
students as much as possible,
and we're also studying the
impact on their performance.
So this is a national
conversation that's emerged.
I know a number of other school districts
are grappling with this,
but we have studied,
and we know that
district-wide, when we look
at quarter one performance
of our students in 2019
versus quarter one performance
of our students in 2020,
we have had a 15% increase
in F grades district-wide.
There is a variance across schools
with actually decreases,
particularly in some of our lower grades,
and also increases in
some of our high schools
where we're seeing larger
total numbers of students
with Fs.
And so that's really pushing us
to think about student engagement
in a couple of different ways.
Like how do we support kids
to make sure they're coming,
and then when they're coming,
how do we support them to be successful
in this completely new
learning environment?
- When you did some of these home visits,
what did people tell you why
their kids weren't showing up
to the Microsoft Teams classroom?
What were the explanations
you've been hearing?
- Yeah, there are a number of reasons
which are very legitimate.
So some families faced challenges
with the device they originally received
having already been broken
and not feeling like they
had a resources or a solution
in order to have that fixed.
And in order to address that, actually,
the district recently
launched 13 regional hubs
throughout the city
where we're providing a
number of in-person supports
to families, including
actually, device repair,
online learning support,
mental health resources.
Actually, we are offering COVID
testing to support families.
And so to help make that
not continue to be an issue.
In the early stages of this work,
when I was out in
neighborhoods, in some ways,
families just didn't feel
like they had all of the clear
communication and information
about what was available to them,
what they were supposed to
do, how they to participate.
And so that's why the home
visits were so important
because it really helped us, face-to-face,
describe to someone what to do,
get their cellphone number
and just solve the
problem alongside of them.
We also launched an online
learning help hotline.
We've had over 2,000 calls to date there
so that families can to call in and say,
"Gosh, I need help this isn't working.
I don't know what to do.
How do I enroll now that
so much is so different?"
So those are a few of the things
that families shared with us
and some of the things that we've done
to try to support them and address that.
- So it sounds like
it's, in some categories,
just tech difficulties
and then probably a little
bit of an activation energy
of just not knowing how to
engage in this new world.
On the other issue,
you mentioned the students
failing disproportionately,
especially at the high school level.
How do y'all categorize that?
How much of that is the access issue?
We just talked about how much of that
is kind of stress and mental health
and anxiety and depression
and how much of that
is just something else.
- So we're actually studying
the relationship right now
between student performance and attendance
to see what the relationship is there.
We've also been actively
engaging in focus groups
with our students to hear from them,
what their perceptions
are about this challenge,
what ideas they have, how they feel.
We've heard a number of things
from students, themselves.
Students have articulated
that this is hard on them,
and it's hard on their teachers
that they sometimes are challenged
by the number of platforms
and what's required of them
to submit assignments.
They talked about examples
where they had submitted work,
but their teacher didn't receive it.
They talked about the expectation
for submission of work,
feeling as though we're not in school,
we're at home, we're online,
but my teacher's expectation
for turning things in on time
hasn't really changed,
and it's really not
sensitive to where I am,
in terms of having to provide
care for a younger sibling
or having to be a caregiver in my own home
or having other responsibilities.
So I think students are
facing a number of things.
We also heard about from
kids, just like you said, Sal,
where really, their mental
health is suffering.
They feel isolated, they feel alone.
They say, "I wake up in
the morning, it's dark.
I get on my computer, I
finish school, it's dark,
and I don't have the
same social engagement."
So one thing I didn't speak
to earlier was our district
was actually one of the
first school districts.
Now, I think it was the first
school district nationally,
certainly large urban
to welcome students back
for in-person instruction
after the spring closure.
So we started preparing
and launched in-person
instruction in summer
and had only like three cases
in our schools at that time.
And then opened the school year
with three different
sort of implementations.
One was an in-person
opportunity for learning,
matching teachers who were
willing to teach in-person
with students who wanted
to learn in-person
or whose families wanted
them to learn in-person.
We also launched a learning centers.
So these students were learning online,
but were able to come to
an educational environment
with the support of other educators,
like dean school, culture facilitators,
assistant principals, paraeducators,
academic interventionists,
to make sure that they have
the support they needed
for the assignment submission
and the online participation.
And then we also had
almost 80% of our students
participating just online.
But unfortunately, because of
increases in infection rates
at the very end of November,
we had to shift to just
online learning again.
And so these challenges
that some of our high
school students are facing
are actually increasing, not decreasing,
with their siblings not being
able to go to learning centers
and learn, and them if they benefited
from it learning in-person.
So that's why we're talking
to them to learn from them
about the challenges they're facing
and to move to strategies that make sense
for a pathway to success,
including supporting our
own educators and guidance
on equitable grading
practices, for example.
- I mean, on that last piece,
this is something we've always
talked about at Khan Academy,
pre pandemic, this social mastery learning
that if you get a C or B or an F,
that you should always have
an opportunity to remediate
and get it to an A level,
especially when COVID seems important,
because we all know what it
does to a student's self-esteem.
And frankly, if they
have a gap in something,
they should be able to fill it in,
otherwise, they'll have trouble
with more advanced topics.
Do you see mechanisms by which y'all can,
these kids who are failing
or getting worse grades
that they normally would, to
be able to do makeup work,
so to speak, to maybe improve their grades
so it doesn't have a lasting
implication for their life.
- Yeah, in fact, what you're describing
is something I'm really
personally passionate about.
I was a math educator
and so much of our work,
leading up into this pandemic,
with the current student
performance in the district,
we have a number of students already
who would be considered
one or more years behind.
And so a really huge part of our work
is providing tiered interventions
to those students and making sure
that they have the academic time and space
to do that work, beyond just continuing
with high quality grade level instruction.
And so we do have a foundation
around what you specifically spoke to,
which is course recovery.
We've done work over
the last couple of years
to have strong course
recovery structures in place.
Over the last summer,
we had students recover about 600 courses.
And that's something that we'll build upon
as we move forward.
I think our job right now,
given where we are in the school year,
is to think about an enact strategies
to prevent some of that with our educators
so that that work can be done
before students find
themselves in that space.
And so not only are we doing work
for success with grade level instruction,
but we're also actually
expanding and pursuing
with this unique structure,
with differentiated schedules,
with things being online.
There are actually also opportunities
to provide direct services
and interventions to students
in a way that...
We can do in-person,
but the online structures have some value.
In fact, in our high school,
we have students really
need reading interventions.
I mean, I realized at that point,
most students are using reading as a tool
to learn and achieve
in their core courses,
but we've made a deep commitment
to addressing students' learning gaps.
So we're launching and we've done work.
District-wide, in fact,
our goal is to reach over
9,000 students in tier three,
reading interventions,
using this opportunity
and being able to flexibly group them.
'Cause they're not in a
brick and mortar building
in one space, they can only
come together at one time,
we can actually pull across
schools and across classrooms
to do some deep interventions,
whether those be
one-on-one or three-on-one.
So this is all work that we
have underway, we're pursuing,
and we just hope to expand,
and to your point, to continue
to leverage the resources,
like Khan Academy and
math to help support that.
- Yeah, no, the dream
scenario is the students
show mastery on Khan Academy
that y'all give them.
Give them credit, but we
can talk about that offline.
There's a question related
to this from a YouTube niche,
seven, eight, six,
and there's actually
three questions in here,
each of which are pretty big.
They're asking, does
online school work well
for both teachers and students?
We've talked a little bit
about where it's not working
so well for students.
I am curious about the
teacher side of things.
What are you hearing from teachers
about what's not working for them
or are there some things that
are working well for them?
- Yeah, great question.
I think if I answered
that with a broad stroke,
a yes or a no, I would not be
attending to the nuance here
because obviously, our teaching force,
like other teachers especially,
we're a diverse set of educators
with lots of different
experiences and perspectives.
And so the things that
I've heard from educators
that are working well,
one is, obviously we are in a pandemic,
and so there are a number of educators
who have clearly expressed their concerns
about teaching in-person.
And so I think the opportunity
to teach students online,
educators are thankful
for that opportunity
for their own safety.
But I will say we also have
had a strong group of educators
teach in-person,
and we've invested in a
significant amount of PPE
and resources to help make
those safe environments
for educators and students.
Teachers have said they
feel supported by us.
So we adopted a learning
management system called Schoology.
We ensured that we procured
and provided to educators
all of the online options
for their existing programs.
So we didn't force them to
learn something completely new
just to do it online,
we really transitioned
their existing content
to a digital platform.
We also complimented the
use of Schoology with Teams
and have made iterative improvements there
for teachers to deliver instruction.
And we've really put our
teachers at the center,
meaning them delivering
instruction each day to students
we think is a real priority
in our implementation.
I think teachers have grown themselves
in their digital
literacies and capacities,
and they actually see growth in kids.
And especially our teachers
who are serving our youngest students,
it's really fun to talk to them
about the things kids
have done on computers
and online platforms
where they've had success
that they didn't anticipate.
And teachers still feel deeply
connected to their students.
So outside of using a computer,
they are connecting with them.
I talked to teachers who
go to their students' homes
to bring them things and
work to make them successful.
So I think educators still
feel equivalently committed
to their own students.
It varies.
Different kids have different supports,
different prior experiences.
And so there are strong
examples of students
who learned new 21st century skills
that they didn't previously have.
We're a Microsoft district,
so we've leveraged like Class Notebook,
Microsoft Whiteboard,
and a number of other...
I'm not coming up with all the platforms,
but our kids have learned
to use these things.
And honestly, they're things,
as a professional, I use also.
And I think some of our students
have enjoyed a little bit of autonomy.
And so I will say there
are positive things
that will have long-term implications
for what in-person learning looks like.
Because I think kids will find
just writing a notebook
paper potentially archaic
now that they have their own device.
And there are struggles
for educators and for teachers in this.
But we actually, as educators,
I'm really glad that question was asked
because we're so focused on like,
what are we gonna do better,
but we do need to also reflect
on what kinds of things
have benefited students.
And I'll name one last thing as a benefit,
and that is expanded equitable access.
So we've actually been able
to expand students' access
to dual enrollment in the district
with our university partners.
Because it wasn't happening in-person,
so we weren't limited to just one school.
So we have students
participating across schools,
and so we've been able
to serve more students.
And so I think that also has
implications district-wide
for when we return.
How do we make sure every
student in the district
who wants to take calc three can
with a university professor?
- No, that's great.
Well, these conversations always
go by faster than I expect.
Thank you so much for joining us,
and frankly, thank you for the work
that you and all of the other educators,
not just in Detroit, but around the world
are doing right now to keep kids learning.
But it shows that y'all are
doing, I would say, better
than what we could hope for,
given how strains and circumstances are.
And there's a lot to worry
about with these kids who seem
to be kind of falling off
and failing or not engaged,
but there's many things to be hopeful for,
and it's because of your tireless efforts.
So thank you for that.
- No, thank you, Sal.
I get to say these things,
but I certainly do not do them alone.
And our superintendent's
leadership through this time
and actually our school boards
leadership during this time,
like everyone in our
organization is deeply focused
on putting students first.
And we're committed to continue
to problem solve with the
community and elevate solutions
to improve what they're experiencing now
and support them in the years to come.
So thank you so much for
having me, and I appreciate it.
- Thanks for joining us.
Well, thank you, everyone,
for joining this conversation.
Hope you got as much out of that as I did,
obviously there's a lot of
things to be worried about
because of COVID.
Some of these were trends
that were going on even before COVID
and they've just gotten worse
with kids gaps, et cetera.
But there's some really
good leadership out there
in the country, in the world
that is making some efforts
and I think thinking about things
in really interesting ways.
So thanks for joining this week.
This was the last Homeroom for this week.
And we might take a little bit
of a hiatus for the holidays.
So depending, but it might be the new year
before we see each other again.
So happy holidays.
See you later.
(text chimes)